kleine holz kabinen mitten in der
berliner city
diese sorgen jetzt für ordentlich ärger
denn eigentlich sind es toiletten doch
sich den mitten auf dem straßenstrich
und sind dort einigen menschen ein dorn
im auge
seit 2008 zehn stehen zwei bio toiletten
aus holz am schöneberger straßenstrich
und dienen den rund 180 straßen
prostituierten als stilles örtchen
allerdings fungiert sie auch zum ort an
dem die damen freier bedienen können der
bedarf ist groß
regelmäßig bedienen die prostituierten
ihre feier direkt auf der straße und das
auch am hellichten tag ein riesen
ärgernis also ich würde sie zum eigenen
schutz auch von dieser damen vielleicht
das sowie in hamburg gestalten ja dass
man da ein viertel haight anlaufstation
und für die damen es ist sicherlich auch
sicher auch in bonn wurden solche
vorrichtung stellen gebaut genügend
platz bieten solche liebes garagen
allemal
doch in berlin setzt man auf ein
platzsparendes mittel die fördert das
projekt liebes toilette und möchte mit
drei weiteren exemplaren den
straßenstrich noch schöner machen
das frauenmagazin emma reagierte
schockiert das sei ein tiefstand der
zivilisation kathrin vogel
frauenpolitische sprecherin der cdu
fraktion ist ähnlich empört drei weitere
dieser menschenverachtenden boxen seien
völlig inakzeptabel
auch die kosten für die
verschönerungsmaßnahmen ist beachtlich
6000 euro miete kostet das chalet die
steuerzahler bei geplanten fünf boxen
werden gleich 30.000 im monat fällig ein
teures vergnügen für ein stilles örtchen
das auch anderweitig genutzt werden soll
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren